if we've learned
anything in this pandemic is that we are
dangerously
dependent for our pharmaceuticals
medical supplies and equipment
on the rest of the world that's white
house trade advisor peter navarro
talking about the need to increase the
manufacture of
pharmaceutical supplies here in the u.s
the coven 19 pandemic exposed
major shortages in the nation's drug and
medical supply chains
a deal navarro brokered involving
eastman kodak
is now on hold over financial issues but
earlier this year he was key in awarding
a contract worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
to a little-known virginia company
promising to revamp the way medicines
are made and distributed
so what is this so this is our catalyst
lab the grand plan to streamline
america's pharmaceutical industry
was launched at virginia commonwealth
university's college of engineering
in richmond our tour begins with dr
frank gupton
so the catalyst would go into the tubes
that are inside these heaters
he oversees this lab where chemists are
working on new ways to manufacture
medications and so this is what is going
to innovate
this is part of it flow is a company
trying to bring back the pharmaceutical
supply chain to the u.s
they went to india and china where labor
costs were lower two years ago his
business partner dr eric edwards
approached dr gupton
with a goal to make affordable generic
drugs right here at home
i was already witnessing massive drug
shortages
that were plaguing this country these
are essential medicines and their
ingredients
that really nagged me and it was a
struggle the market
is immense americans filled the
equivalent of 5.8 billion
30-day prescriptions in 2018 alone
but in 2019 the food and drug
administration estimated
that 80 of active pharmaceutical
ingredients
and 40 of finished medications were
manufactured overseas
mainly in china and india this allows
you to be able to run these processes
continuously
lowe's key process a method called
continuous manufacturing
they say it will increase quality
control reduce the risk of counterfeit
medications
and provide transparency in labeling
we're creating an
end-to-end manufacturing infrastructure
and supply chain
right here in the united states from
precursor chemical
to active pharmaceutical ingredient to
finished drug into a vial or a syringe
in the 1990s american companies began to
rely on a manufacturing process
that utilizes large-scale equipment and
cheap labor
this method thrives under relaxed
environmental regulations
often found overseas the result
a weakened system here at home is the
supply chain broken
not only is the american medical supply
chain broken the pricing and
reimbursement system is broken
this broken system became apparent in
march
when the coronavirus pandemic depleted
the national stockpile of personal
protective equipment
and critical medications
demand for these supplies was global and
it brought overseas imports to a halt
this made flow's efforts not just
relevant but critical
so what i have right now is like it's a
syringe filled with
my starting material so we're going to
take this and turn it into like a male
area drag
developing a new drug typically costs
more than two and a half
billion dollars and takes more than a
decade
lowe's founders say their method will
reduce both time
and expense it's all going to be
together
streamlining the supply chain making
sure that we have the highest quality
that americans and patients deserve flow
is also looking to bridge the gap
between
underpriced generics and those higher
priced drugs with a more
limited market for children or for rare
diseases
there was no profit in these medicines
we've driven the pricing of some of
these generic medicines into the ground
a bottle of fiji water at an airport
costs more than a life-saving vial of
medication
edwards has been in the business for
years and has faced some criticism
kaleo the company he co-founded with his
twin brother then left
seven years ago came under congressional
scrutiny
after pricing for a popular overdose
antidote rose by
600 percent in three years
the company authorized a cheaper and
generic drug
soon after how do you meet that
skepticism
going into a relatively new company
with these goals i was not involved in
any pricing decisions and i was in
charge of innovation
this is all about innovation and
teamwork to try to
fix a broken pharmaceutical pricing
reimbursement and distribution system
that has left a lot of these generic
medicines out of reach for patients
flo's partnership includes virginia
commonwealth university's medicines for
all institute which is backed in part
by the bill and melinda gates foundation
and flo could get
even more money from the trump
administration right now about 350
million dollars
their contract can be extended to more
than 800 million dollars
over 10 years dana michelle really
interesting
access that's what people are looking
for access that they can afford